another celebrity revealed on the masked
singer
I loved the anonymity I loved like you
know I'm so bad at keeping a secret you
guys and so for me to not tell my family
what I'm doing it's just been it's been
a ball Ricky says it's been a ball but
it's also been an emotional journey
dressed in costume as the raven ricky
hinted at grieving along from death to
love to birthing you just a love 11:11
what is that somebody that just passed
away my greatest joy is being a mother
to my flock after Ricky's reveal she
explained why she chose the Raven the
Raven is about metamorphosis it's about
death but it's also about rebirth and I
went through ass of my husband last year
and this really was an opportunity for
me to sort of share my my journey
through through his loss just moments
after she was eliminated ET was with the
masked singers judges at Fox's TCA
presentation the raven was unmasked this
week and we found out it was miss Ricki
Lake and she revealed an emotional
journey that led her to this point can
you talk a little bit about that and
what it meant for you to hear her
explain that to you guys you know it it
was an emotional journey and to hear
that she had lost her husband and how
heart-wrenching that was I mean we all
felt it in the room and and I was so
proud of her because it's not easy to do
even if you're a celebrity to get up
there and wear a costume like that and
sing and then also to be vulnerable to
share your story god bless her a lot of
the contestants you know some of them
are there to have a good time and and
some of them are there to really it's a
cathartic experience for them you can
yeah I remember being very emotional
when when she you know when she opened
up about that and and yeah I mean all of
us were really choked up and in some in
tears you know so you really you you you
just to see just to see the the
motivation behind you know why why she
did it was it was actually very
inspiring I remember I'm
after after filming that it was like wow
this is this is what the show is all
about I was moved she shared a little of
that continuously through each clue
package I think it took a lot of courage
and it was really this show in a mad
bizarre way it can be such a
transformational journey for these
contestants and it's family fun it's a
good time but the beauty of it is it's
quite emotional as well